is there anything in the laptop you saw
that you've never told anybody
there's a couple things
and why haven't you told anybody
well
i've never thought it was my
responsibility to tell anybody other
than the authorities okay it's it's
and i and i get it i never wanted to go
to the media i never wanted to go to the
press and i
and i i know why and that's because i
knew the media would focus on the the
sex and the drugs and the
and not the
the can the the wholesale of our state
department for personal gain or the
national security concerns or the
embarrassment that
we will endure when all this comes out
it's that
i saw criminal activity i needed to get
this to the proper authorities the
proper authorities bailed so i went to
members of congress not directly my
uncle and then when that didn't get any
traction
i came out from the shadows because i
was again scared i didn't want to lose
my business i don't want to be chased
from my home i didn't want i wanted to
have nobody know i existed
but i wanted the truth to get out and
then i realized the only way that was
going to happen is if i knocked on the
door of the
lawyer for the president of the united
states and that worked
and when you say members of congress i
don't need names but did you go to
republican democrat you're in delaware
who'd you go to we my uncle and my
father only approached members of
congress that were conservatives
for obvious reasons so you went to
republicans and you got rebuffed they
had no love for what you had to see what
happened so and i i've had discussions
with some of these individuals that
were presented with this information and
i get it
during the we're talking about february
through
june july of 2020 so there was a
pandemic going on there was also we're
coming off the heels of
russia
three years of russia russia russia
everybody is so paranoid of being
caught up in another uh conspiracy
uh jeopardizing the
political embarrassment uh and and and
they have a good reason because look at
what happened with things like dominion
you know this conspiracy goes out there
oh dominion's changing changing all
these votes around
and then they prove it's wrong now
dominion gets to file a 16.7 million
dollar billion dollar lawsuit and go
after all the people that got hooked
into this disinformation these
disinformation ploys and that's why i
warned congress again when there was an
individual out in switzerland trying to
say he's found 400 and he's given these
drives we saw
uh
who's that the young guy he was parade
around congress going i have uh i have a
copy of the drive he was on c-speed yeah
yeah uh forgot the name of the guy yeah
a young kid so no republicans were even
willing to listen to your stuff the
patient guard intercepted my uncle and
my father and and
never let them get past the door
so let me go back let me go back to the
question so i want to stay focused on
this so there's a couple things you said
that no one knows about that's only you
that you've kept to yourself
are those couple things like
tremendously bigger than what the public
has already been rumored that was in the
laptop or no it's just a couple things
you just kept away from everybody well
again i don't i never felt like it was
my responsibility to share that no
that's not what i'm asking what i'm
asking is those things things that
you've kept to yourself are they much
bigger and heavier stuff than all the
other things um
personally yes okay but but for the
country and for the purpose of why i
gave it to the laptop no it's it's more
of i
through hunter's behavior i should have
a fear for my life okay so it's more
more
speculation hunter with a minor than it
is about link to the president and what
he did with ukraine or deal side deals
right it's more personal link 200 not
linked to the father it's linked to
hunter okay perfect so let's set that
aside that's you know
hunter's dealing that he's he's got to
go deal with okay so
those two things the couple things that
you haven't told anybody have you told
that to the person you trust the most
which is your father
does anybody know is it just you you're
the only person no the people i trust
now okay so what i would say to you is
i probably wouldn't hang on to that
because if you do you're not protected
you know
and i'm not
i don't know if you understand what i'm
saying here because if you if you're
sitting on i was like
you know all of a sudden let's put them
on suicide watch that's kind of people
get put on suicide watches oh i had to
make that video a long time ago yeah
well then you did make that video oh
yeah what he's basically asking you
about well no so no you don't need a
secret yeah yeah like like i'm i'm
if i show up i'm killing i'm not gonna
kill exactly yeah i'm not gonna kill him
like john mcafee right i am never gonna
commit suicide just so you guys know in
jail yeah so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]